qu'est ce que ce smartphone a de mieux
qu'un web et smart 2019
ou alors encore un au nord d'islamabad
mois là des gens que je goûte d'eau
partie des gens que je goûte d'eau par
la d encausse goutte d'eau il ya que de
ça je vous remets droit c'est un peu de
travers voilà comme ça on n'a pas comme
ça pour garder les os que je vous donne
je parle beaucoup en ce début d'année
2010 9 je vous ai parlé autour du web et
smart 2019
je vous ai également parlé du au nord
d'israël a aujourd'hui je vous parle du
xiaomi raid me nots est cool
le raid minutes 5 avec un énorme
smartphones l'année dernière pour les
petits prix avec des pertes de housses
pas ou pas complètement ouf mais des
pertes vraiment intéressante un
excellent rapport qualité-prix un
smartphone qui a été récompensée qui a
été reconnu que j'ai trouvé moi
franchement intéressante
il ya eu le nez minaude syspro bien
moins d'1 go mais bien et la lorraine
minutes 7 alors serez minutes 7 n'est
pas encore dispo en france
vous pouvez la voir en import notamment
par la boutique dick mol ça vous
intéresse je vous aime bien les en bas
on va jeter un coup d'oeil au morceau
final serait demi note 7 est intéressant
qu'est ce qu'il peut proposer
on en reparlera probablement plus tard
lorsqu'il arrivera en france sur la
version globale là c'est une version qui
est dispo uniquement en mandarin si vous
parlez des mandarins c'est bien et en
anglais rassurez-vous néanmoins vous
pouvez télécharger le plextor pour avoir
vos applications donc là dessus vous
êtes quand même tranquille par contre il
faut parler la langue de shakespeare
d'un autre côté ça peut vous forcer à
parler anglais il peut y avoir des côtés
positifs alors se réduit note 7 est ce
qu'il est intéressant oui non quels sont
ses atouts mais au final comment il se
positionne notamment par rapport au web
et smart 2019 et au nord d'islamabad où
je vais vous montrer la boîte moi je
trouve qu'elle est quand même pas mal
et ce qui est intéressant et très subtil
vous allez le voir c'est que la marque
maintenant c'est vraiment la marque red
me c'est pas la marque shiomi qui est
mis en avant et vous le voyez même ça
directement sur le smartphone ça c'est
vraiment intéressant
regardez là il est bien écrit
red me batte xiaomi ça fait penser au
repos cophan poko phone bachir mieux on
se demande si rennes lui ne peut pas
venir une marque à part ou alors
simplement si c'est un coup de marketing
ça ce que c'est ça c'est intéressant
puis on suivra ça de près à l'intérieur
de la boîte et ya rien de complètement
fou fou si j'arrive à l'ouvrir
on va retrouver alors sa foi un petit
adaptateur mais normalement on a tous
des adaptateurs là dessus c'est pas de
la recharge rapide donc vous en fichez
usb usb type c vous avez de quoi ouvrir
votre tiroir de cartes sim vous avez une
petite coque de protection qui peut
avoir son intérêt bon y'a rien de bien
dans la boîte rentrer regardez vous me
les trois smartphones d'un côté là vous
avez le xiaomi là vous avez le au nord
et là vous avez le huawei voyez que sur
le modèle de chiots me j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya un peu plus de bordures en eau
que sur les autres modèles est par
contre il ya plus de bordures en bas
emballé menton sont quand même un peu
plus petits ça c'est vraiment gros
points de différence d'un point de vue
esthétique entre ces trois smartphones
maintenant si je me concentre que sur
l'aspect purement esthétique je trouve
que il ya un boulot de fait de la part
de chiots me on est sur un smartphone
qui reviennent bien fait le doubs en
plastique à donner place à dos en vertu
d'un côté un peu plus premium très
classe toujours le capteur d'empreinte
digitale au double module photo mais
seront en parler juste après que petit
flash led dessous je vous le disais
l'apparition de rennes i buy chômiste
son côté bouton volume bouton pour
l'allumer et l'éteindre vous avez sur le
dessous un haut parleur de l'usb titre
c'est une petite grille avec un micro
ici son côté vous avez votre tiroir de
cartes sim avec soin denanot steam soit
une nano 6004 microïds et sur le dessus
vous avez de l'infrarouge votre prise
jack est ici un micro antibruit donc ça
c'est plutôt cool
on a l'impression qu'il ya une montée en
gamme du fait notamment d'avoir ce petit
dos en verre je trouve assez bien très
sympa maintenant on va regarder
du point de vue de l'écran et vous allez
voir que franchement ça c'est vraiment
un énorme atout pour ce smartphone c'est
un écran lcd 6 points 3 pouces de pur
bonheur ratio 19.5 neuvième résolution
eiffage des plus 2340 par 1080 pixels
petite encoche goutte d'eau qui
franchement très discrète c'est un
smartphone avec un écran qui est très
lumineux là je n'ai pas poussé à fond si
je le pousse à fond franchement il est
extrêmement lumineux en extérieur c'est
vraiment agréable lorsque vous avez du
soleil il est franchement hyper agréable
pour regarder
des hausses assez aussi super bien ce
qui est très drôle lorsque joue par
exemple un texte vga et je le serai en
tête c'est que ça me laisse de la place
au niveau de l'encoche voyez ça me prend
pas tout l'écran là j'ai quelques l'axé
sur la version 3 giga de ram
je pense que si j'avais la version 4
gigas de ram ça irait quand même un peu
plus vite lâché en configuration moyenne
sur ce jeu bon ça va ça fonctionne c'est
pas complètement dingue on a un écran
qui est costaud avec un corning gorilla
glass 5 ça c'est cool
il ya un autre point qui est intéressant
sur la partie multimédia c'est le deux
parce que je trouve que l'audio même si
on a un seul haut-parleur qui se situe
là le dos et quand même de qualité et ça
c'est franchement intéressant je vous
laisse écouter
pour moi le jeu est franchement
intéressant on a une qualité qui est
cool c'est un peu en pointe différence
qu'on a par rapport au ps marc 2019 et
par rapport au nord des slides où le son
est très médium très criard et pas très
agréable là par contre il est beaucoup
plus agréable
il ya un autre point qui est intéressant
c'est la partie casque parce que vous
avez une prise jack qui est préservée
prise jack sur le dessus et en plus de
ça et la différence également par
rapport au ps marquée par rapport au
nord des slides et il ya du son il ya du
volume
il ya même beaucoup de sens donc faut
faire gaffe à pas trop en dessous par
contre à côté de ça ça marche bien le
spectre est cool
donc si vous voulez écouter au casque
c'est bien si vous l'écoutez sans casque
vous serez pas déçu pour moi de ce point
de vue en tout cas multimédia vidéos
jeux vidéo
schumi a bien réussi sa copie maintenant
il ya un autre qui est intéressant sur
smartphone à la différence du renmin
note 5 et du renmin autres six pros avec
leurs épisodes 7
on a un soc de qualcomm qui est un peu
plus performant avant on avait un sla
dragonne 636 elorn instinct dragonne 660
alors fondamentalement ça n'a pas bien
changé un peu l'histoire parce que ça va
être compliqué de nous en rendre compte
vous en rendez compte c'est que vous
êtes franchement un expert voir sur
experts pas se faire est venu c'est très
très compliqué ce qu'ils peuvent faire à
mon avis la différence avec les 3 giga
de ram 4 gigas de ram sur du jeu mais
sinon vous sentirez pas on instaure qui
pas mal sûr en tout 240 4232 c'est pas
mal pour moi c'est un smartphone va
tourner et 90% des applications que vous
allez trouver sur le plextor vous serez
pas déçus aura pas de problème ça marche
bien c'est cool c'esr applique donc ça
c'est aussi un gros point positif est en
fait ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que vous
avez deux versions je vous disais 3 giga
de ram ou 4 gigas de ram vous pouvez le
trouver
soit en 3 giga de ram 32 gigas de
stockage soit 4 gigas de ram 64 giga de
stockage moi j'ai la version 3 32 et la
version 4 64 vous pouvez retrouver chez
dick mol à 239
une fois de plus le lien se trouve juste
en bas alors je vous le disais la tue
c'est une rom chinois c'est à dire que
vous allez avoir toutes vos applications
chinoise
vous n'allez pas avoir d'applications
européenne vous n'allez pas voir
d'autres applications mais vous pouvez
les télécharger
notamment le ps histoire pour pouvoir
ensuite récupérer tout ce que vous
voulez je vous explique comment ça
marche si vous voulez faire si vous
l'achetez c'est très simple vous êtes
dans l'app store
keops l'application native c'est pas ici
l'app store d'apple
vous allez ensuite venir chercher vous
allez chercher google vous voyez si vous
avez des comme ça tout de suite c'est un
peu compliqué vous recherchez google
vous allez avoir bien évidemment youtube
crown tout ça tout ça vous allez pouvoir
télécharger cette application ici avec
cette icône là mais de là vous allez
pouvoir tout venir télécharger ça vous
télécharge tout ce que vous voulez
google pleine campagne ici et ça donc ça
c'est assez intéressant
ensuite vous avez votre place store de
la ve télécharger tout ce que vous
voulez donc à ses couleurs vous qu'il
vous retrouve effectivement avec tous
des affiches chinoise directement dessus
mais bon pourquoi pas après vous les
effacer pas ce que vous voulez du point
de vue de l'ouest lorsque vous l'achetez
va tourner sur me why neuf avec android
8 oreo et vous pourrez tout de suite
faire la mise à jour pour arriver sur me
white 10 avec android spy
autre point qui est important là dessus
et tremblements le point le plus
intéressant c'est l'autonomie
vous avez une grosse batterie de 4000
milliards erreur vous l'aviez déjà dans
leurs ennemis note 5
l'autonomie reste toujours très bonne ça
dépendra une fois de plus de votre
utilisation si vous bourriner vous
garderez une journée si vous êtes plus
cool vous le garderai une journée ni
voire pourquoi pas deux jours mentionné
à ce qui est très intéressant c'est que
vous avez déjà de la recharge en usb
type c'est pour un smartphone à ce prix
là c'est plutôt rare pour ça ça mérite
d'être souligné et autres potes est très
intéressant et les compatibles quick
charge 4c de la recharge rapide vous
allez changer très rapidement en peu de
temps alors la kul cherche 4 n'est pas
compris dans la boîte il faut l'acheter
à part mais si vous en avez déjà si vous
voulez en faire l'acquisition les
pouvoir recharger votre smartphone très
rapidement et s'associe à un point de
différenciation par rapport au ps marc
2019 et par rapport aux ordis light donc
vu qu'on a même gamme de prix
c'est vraiment un point positif voilà
maintenant l'épineuse question des
appareils photos ça vous allez voir ça
c'est intéressant vous avez à l'arrière
un double module photo cl vous aura pas
échappé
48 mégapixels c'est le capteur qu'on
retrouve notamment dans le haut nord
view 20 dans le ps mars 2010
au nord du slice c'est le capteur sony
nex-5 186 qui à son capteur de 48 méga
pixels tandis que le deuxième de 5
mégapixels viendra en renfort pour le
mode portrait et bien évidemment de
l'intérieur dfi ciel est à l'avant vous
avez une petite caméra de 13 médias
pixels je trouve le rendu des photos
vraiment hyper qualitatif là vous êtes
sur des fleurs du mois de février
il ya un vrai beau rendu des couleurs
c'est pas sûr saturé et le rendu est
assez naturel bien évidemment tous
optimisée grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle sa marche absolument bien
sur cette photo la boyer on arrive sur
des photos là avec un peu plus de soleil
ça va je possède vraiment très joli il
ya vraiment une très très très belle
restitution là il a un peu plus de mal
qu'il fait parce que la fleur est plus
petit
y voyez n'arrive pas à faire le point on
arrive ensuite sur la caméra de celle
fip
je trouve que le rendu est pas mal c'est
pas complètement officines mais ça fait
un beau boulot là avec le soleil
il ya un beau contraste c'est sympa les
couleurs sont préservés je trouve que
vraiment de ce point de vue là le boulot
est plutôt cool le mode portrait est
aussi assez bien réussi lorsque vous
allez complexifier la scène ça m'a bien
des tours et le pouce et là ça ne les
tours bien entre les doigts la photo de
nu c'est parce que le plus fou qui va y
avoir mais bon dans l'absolu on n'est
pas là pour faire de cette nuit avec un
smartphone comme celui là ce raid
minutes 7 fonctionne plutôt bien en
photo c'est pas un vidéophone c'est pas
un smartphone qui est complètement
optimisé pour la vidéo vous pouvez
filmer les jusqu'en 1080p à 60 images
par secondes voire carrément à 120
images par seconde en vol au dessus
qu'est ce que ce smartphone a de mieux
qu'un web et smart 2010 neuf mois lors
encore un au nord d'israël pour moi la
photo va être meilleur en plein jour le
fait qu'il ait une recharge en usb tice
et ça c'est cool qu'ils soient
compatibles quid charge 4 je trouve que
l'écran est un peu au dessus par rapport
aux deux autres smartphones lo'jo de
bien meilleure qualité que ce soit avec
le haut parleur et au casque maintenant
on peut pas tout avoir je trouve que a
contrario il va avoir un menton qui va
être un peu plus proéminent qui va voir
un bord supérieur qui va être un peu
plus prononcée ceux du point de détail
mais quand même un petit peu plus je
trouve un peu plus lourd by par contre
en 4 gigas de ram + 64 giga de stockage
extensible à 239 euros je trouve
franchement bien je sais pas ce que vous
en pensez vous est ce que vous avez
acheté leurs ennemis note 5/10 très
grand
succès dont christian vous êtes
nombreuses et nombreux à l'avoir acheté
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en moins
aux commentaires et comment est ce que
vous le trouvez par rapport à celui là
aurait 2 min 7 s que l'aurait minaude 7
vous fait de l'oeil
oui non quoi comment vous invite à
marquer tout ça en commentaire et à
visionner ma playlist pourra découvrir
mes autres tests le web et smart 2019 le
au nord disent leur nos revues vin et
tout plein de smartphones et n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner parce que d'ici
quelques jours on part découvrir les
nouveaux smartphones de samsung
directement à londres et on va également
au mwc qui est le plus gros salon de
téléphonie mobile international
allez découvrir plein de nouveaux
produits ou itunes d'abord à d'autres il
ya 2009 qui va être présenté va y avoir
plein de trucs donc ça va être hyper
cool d'ici là je vous embrasse comportez
vous bien et à très bientôt